first light and the start of the battle
for Mo's effect the three-pronged pesh
MERGA assault on villages and towns 14
miles from Iraq Second City a mixture of
low-tech and high-tech infantry dug in
after two years of controlling you from
far out our convoy was continuously
targeted with motors sending plumes of
smoke and dust into the air around us
Islamic state set oil fires along the
route turning the sky an apocalyptic
black it's designed to cover their
movement to protect them from air
strikes little thing as targets were
destroyed with enormous bomb
then the towns and villages themselves
the Kurdish forces spreading out taking
on multiple locations simultaneously we
stopped in an area thought to have been
cleared within minutes though we were
under attack
the Kurd fighters are trying to find a
firing point
on the ground the Peshmerga responded
identifying a suicide bomber in a truck
from the air okay this is about
clearance once inside I begin searching
the hiding is vital
first of one of the first village is
that the Peshmerga to get to they're
literally going street by street trying
to clear out any of the Islamic state if
they're in here they're not sure was
here they're being fired back at now
this could of course be a very long
process even the most insignificant
targets of deadly dangerous at all times
huge city like Mosul will be infinitely
harder but after two years the battle
has begun to at Ramsey Sky News on the
road to Mosul